[Música]
actualizamos la economía en directo
américa de france 24 el himen de zúrich
y en el estudio el visto hemos iniciar
en europa porque alemania usa 9
descartan recurrir al carbón ante la
amenaza de mayores recortes en el
suministro de gas ruso así que es raúl a
pesar de ello las autoridades de
probarnos alemán ya están anunciando que
mantienen la propuesta de abandonar el
uso del carbón para el año 2030 la
medida se presenta prácticamente de
urgencia para asegurar el suministro de
energía y como una respuesta al anuncio
de gazprom de reducir las entregas de
gas hacia europa el uso de carbón
también sería imitado por austria que
autorizó a la empresa btr pot de
convertir una central en energía
eléctrica a partir del gas para que
pueda utilizar carbón
louis y le pregunto cómo está
administrando el gas a alemania y de
cuánto eran las importaciones rusas de
este producto raúl respondiendo a la
segunda pregunta las importaciones de
gas ruso a alemania ascendieron a 142
mil millones de metros cúbicos en 2021
es decir alrededor del 55 por ciento del
gas que consume alemania procede
qué está haciendo alemania bueno según
el ministro finanzas robert halver las
reservas de casa en el país están por el
orden del 50 y 67 por ciento actualmente
y éstas podrían estar en el orden del 80
por ciento para el primero de octubre y
del 90% para el mes de noviembre
adicionalmente el país dispondrá de
recursos por el orden de los 15 mil
millones de euros para la compra de gas
en otros lugares y que reconocen que
será más caro y regresamos a colombia
desde europa louis vamos a hablar de la
expectativa respecto al manejo que le va
a dar la economía el nuevo presidente
electo de este país estamos hablando de
gustavo petro quien en por el próximo
periodo llevará las riendas de una de
las naciones más desiguales en la región
latinoamericana donde según un estudio
del banco mundial el 10 por ciento de
las personas de mayores ingresos tienen
recursos aproximadamente por encima del
11 por ciento de acuerdo con el
departamento administrativo nacional
dane colombia registró un crecimiento en
su producto interno bruto durante el
primer trimestre de 85 por ciento y se
espera de acuerdo con la ocde que éste
sea de 61 % para este año además
presenta una inflación que en el mes de
mayo se ubicó en 6 55 por ciento en el
acumulado de este año y el desempleo se
ubicó en 11,2 por ciento en abril entre
las propuestas de petro a grandes rasgos
se centran en reformas estructurales
para corregir desigualdades basándose en
lo que define como la democratización
del crédito y de los espacios virtuales
para conectar con el saber y
principalmente la democratización de la
tierra y el agua para transformar al
campo en clave productiva de justicia
social adicionalmente propone dos ejes
la transformación energética y detener
la exploración y extracción petrolera
también propone la reforma tributaria
con la cual aspira a aumentar los
ingresos en un 5% recursos que podría
destinar para nuevos gastos es decir
subsidios y proyectos sociales y también
a otros programas mientras tanto espera
reducir el déficit fiscal en cuanto al
comportamiento del dólar que hay mucha
espectativa nuestra compañera daniela
plantón conversó con el experto en
mercado financiero jorge hernando garcía
y esto fue lo que le dio
creo que en el corto plazo el dólar
podría apreciarse con respecto al peso
colombiano principalmente por la alta
incertidumbre y el ruido que genera la
propuesta del presidente electo de
suspender la firma de nuevos contratos
de exploración de hidrocarburos esto
debilitará la actividad petrolera para
crear una política centrada en
energéticos renovables no convencionales
lo anterior podría generar en el mediano
y largo plazo unos fuertes desbalances
macroeconómicos que en ese mediano y
largo plazo a su vez generen una muy
fuerte depreciación del peso colombiano
con respecto al dólar estadounidense
tengamos bien presente que alrededor del
45 por ciento de nuestras exportaciones
corresponden a petróleo y pasamos a
hablar de eeuu porque los trabajadores
de apple votaron para unirse a un
sindicato así eso ocurrió en la ciudad
de maryland y de esta manera se
convierten en los primeros empleados
minoristas que logran sindicalizarse en
la unión americana la historia de la
votación concluyó cuando 65 trabajadores
votar a favor de unirse a la
sindicalización con 33 votos en contra
según cnn una de las razones para
sindicalizarse es la forma en la que se
administra la tienda por encima del
usuario para decir que esta situación
aumenta el deseo de formar sindicatos en
las principales empresas de eeuu algo
que ha crecido durante los últimos años
en ese país nos vamos a ir a asia al
digamos as blanca nueva comisión del
fondo monetario internacional se reunió
con las principales autoridades en
materia económica de esa nación que
dijeron raúl se presenta en medio de la
peor crisis económica para la nación en
los últimos años que ha llevado al país
a una falta de divisas y con ello
dificultar el acceso a la población de
productos básicos como combustibles
alimentos y medicinas en abril la nación
insular suspendió el pago de 12 mil
millones de dólares de deuda externa
esto por primera vez se presente en ese
país y por ello recurrió al fondo
monetario internacional para acceder
tanto a un financiamiento como para
recibir asesoría y así encarrilar sus
finanzas indicadores económicos y
hablando de finanzas
en este caso de los mercados asiáticos
que cerraron de manera mixta sobre todo
porque china decidió mantener sin cambio
sus tasas de préstamos y por ello los
mercados asiáticos en este caso de china
cerraron con leves ganancias cayeron
japón y también corea del sur mientras
tanto en europa las operaciones están
con leves ganancias a lo largo de la
jornada
seguimos en europa vamos a saludar a
quien está en parís a quien más nuestra
periodista ely cola birdie allá vamos